We'd determined that measuring the angle of the sun's rays in Alexandria can be done
as precisely as we like, so this error is negligible, which is interesting.
You may not have thought that this actual measurement seems more difficult than just
verifying something that's vertical, but it turns out this was the negligible one
and this could introduce about 20% error.
Next, we have been measuring distance between Syene and Alexandria
and what is there to say about this one?
To estimate this distance between Syene and Alexandria, surveyors at that time would
time camels using some assumptions based on how quickly a camel would walk,
they would infer a distance between these two cities.
Now, you can probably tell this is not the best way to measure distance.
Maybe his camel walk in a perfectly straight line at constant speed
and the measurement went perfectly, but somehow, I doubt that.
In fact with all the zigzagging and the camel speeding up and slowing down, I'd estimate
the uncertainty here to be about 10-20% and this is truly a pretty large source of error.
An error in distance measurement of 10-20%, well, let's just say 15% for simplicity sake.
We need to propagate this through and determine how much this affects our circumference
measurement--so let's go back to our equation.
And the circumference is 360/α times this distance d.
And this distance has an uncertainty of 15%, which means that instead of being 5,000 stadia,
actually 5,000, plus or minus 750 stadia--so we can do we did last time and say well dmax
the maximum possible value for d would be 5750 stadia, dmin would be 4250 stadia, and we can
calculate circumferences based on that and then use those calculations to determine the percent error.
We note that using d average, so just using this 5000 stadia,
results in the circumference of 46,250 kilometers.
Now, I want you to fill in these blanks.
What is the circumference if we used dmax, so that would be 5000 stadia plus 750 stadia?
Once you've calculated that, how far off percentage-wise is that from 46,250?
Do the same thing for dmin, and as a reminder 1 stadium is 185 meters,
and α, which is this angle here in the equation is 7.2 degrees.
Go ahead and fill this out.